PETE LEPAGE: All right,
welcome, everybody.
My name's Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Chrome team at Google.
JOHN MELLOR: And I'm
John Mellor.
I work on Chrome for Android
web browser in London.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Today we're going to be talking
about High DPI and how
we make the web beautiful.
Everybody here got a
Pixel yesterday,
and it's pretty awesome.
You've all probably been surfing
around a little bit on
it, and you've seen that some
websites look pretty
fantastic, and other sites, uh,
they don't look so good.
So we're going to talk about how
to make all websites look
pretty fantastic.
Now, how many people have
an HDTV at home?
Yeah, pretty much everybody,
right?
It looks beautiful up here.
If you're a sports fan,
everything looks sharp.
It's clear.
You can see all the little
balls, you can see the pucks,
whatever it happens to be.
But every once in a while, you
come across a TV show that's
broadcast in standard def.
And you kind of go, wow,
this looks like--
well, it just looks
bad, right?
It just doesn't look
very good.
We're at the same point with
high DPI displays as we are
with HDTVs five years ago.
For the most part, it's up to
the broadcasters to send out
high def channels.
Well, now it's up to us, as web
developers, to send out
the high def content
to our users.
So we're going to talk about
how we get there.
So let's just sort of think a
little bit about how an HDTV
works and how the high
DPI displays work.
So with a high def TV,
it's got about 1080
pixels high, right?
Well, a standard def image is
only about 480 pixels high.
So you've got two options.
One, you can display the image
at a one-to-one pixel ratio.
So it's not expanded out.
Everything looks sharp.
It looks good.
But you've got all those black
borders around everything, and
it just looks, meh,
not so good.
Or you can blow it up so it fits
the full resolution of
your screen.
And then it starts to
get a little blurry.
And that's what's happening
on high DPI displays.
That's what happens
on your phone.
on the Pixel.
The browser blows those images
up to fit on screen.
So John, there's so many
pixel types that
we got to deal with.
Why don't we talk about
those for a sec.
JOHN MELLOR: So there are
essentially three kinds of
pixels that web developers
need to worry about.
The first kind, it's
a device pixel.
This is one physical hardware
pixel, a single RGP unit in
the display.
And it's the smallest unit,
So then there's a
second kind--
device independent pixel, or
DIP, as we're going to call it
from now on.
It's an abstract unit.
It's a fixed multiple
of device pixels.
So once they're a 2x device,
each device independent pixel,
DIP, is a two-by-two vector
angle of device pixels.
OK,
And the third kind
is CSS pixels.
These are the ones we're all
familiar with from CSS--
the px unit.
And so if you want to follow
best practices, and you've got
a width=devi viewport-- we'll go
into what it means later--
a CSS pixel and a DIP are
initially the same thing,
until you zoom in.
When you zoom in, the CSS
pixels gets scaled up.
But the DIP is a physical
thing, and so that
stays the same size.
OK, so this leads to some
confusion, because they do
seem quite similar,
ultimately.
And in fact, if you read the
specs like CSS and HTML,
you'll notice the specs never
actually refer to these DIPs.
They always talk about
CSS pixels.
And they use that term, CSS
pixels, to refer to both DIPs
and CSS pixels.
So you have to be a little
bit careful.
As web developers, we're most
concerned about CSS pixels,
because that's what we actually
use in our layouts,
and this mysterious device
pixel ratio.
So let's go into a practical
example.
So this is a Nexus Four.
It's a 2x device, and we'll put
on [? developer ?] hats in
a minute to look at what that
actually means and how we
calculate it.
But all you need to know for now
is it's a fixed value for
the device.
The Nexus Four is
also 768 device
pixels wide in portrait.
And to get the mobile device
independent pixels of width,
you divide this by the device
pixel ratio, and you get 384.
The width for this device in CSS
pixels, well, that varies.
So it varies based on the
viewport, which we'll go into
later, and it varies
on the zoom level.
On the mobile site, it'll
often start off
as being 384 pixels.
It'll match them with DIPs.
But on a desktop site, it'll
often start out being 980
pixels wide.
And as you zoom in, the
page is scaled up.
It stays the same width, but
because you can see less of
the page on screen at one time,
the number of CSS pixels
across the width of the screen
decreases when you zoom in.
So Pete, how does the DPI
vary across devices?
PETE LEPAGE: So it's really
one of those fun things.
The device pixel ratio can go
anywhere from one for a simple
1x device, all the way up to
3 with the new Galaxy S IV.
And it's everything
in between.
The Nexus S is a 1.5x device.
The Nexus is a 1.3.
Before this session, John and
I did a little bit of math,
and we figured out, we think
for people sitting in the
front row, that projector
is about a 0.5x display.
But for the people in the
back, it's a 2x display.
And we'll talk about
that in a sec.
So notice that the different
DPIs between the Nexus S and
the Chromebook Pixel is only
four DPI different, right?
Four DPI should not matter
on how much it goes
from a 1.5 to a 2.
It shouldn't matter going back
and forth between the front
row and the back row.
It has to do with the distance
that you're sitting away from
the device.
So I want everybody to do a
little experiment for me.
Take your hand.
Hold it out in front of your
face, just like this.
All right, now look at the
size of your hand.
All right, now bring your hand
right up to your nose, like
right up to your nose.
Notice how your hand
got bigger?
You can take your
hand down now.
Right, your hand got
a lot bigger.
But your hand didn't change
size at all, right?
It comes down to the visual
angle that you're
looking at your hand.
So the device pixel
ratio is really
about that visual angle.
The CSS spec defines a pixel as
the visual angle of a pixel
at 28 inches for a
96 DPI display.
So they've said, all right, a
1x display should have about
96 pixels at 28 inches.
So for a phone, which we hold
much closer, we need it to
have a higher pixel density.
So instead of having a 96 DPI
display, it needs at least
about 160 DPI.
So actually, when we did the
math, this projector is about
a 0.16 DPI, if you ever
want to do this.
Now, if you want to calculate
these out, the formula's here.
You can do this on your own.
It's not really that hard, and
it's kind of fun just to
figure this out.
In fact, your TV at home, if
you've got an HDTV and you're
sitting about six feet away from
it, you've got a high DPI
display at home.
I bet you didn't realize you
probably have multiple high
DPI displays at home.
So we've talked about a lot
of the theoretical stuff.
Let's jump in and talk about the
practical stuff, like how
we actually do this.
JOHN MELLOR: So let's say
you want to build a
high DPI phone site.
OK, so you're looking on Nexus
7 or whatever, and you see
that's 768 device pixels wide.
That's what the spec
sheet says.
You go online, you look at
google.com at Nexus 4 tech
specs, and that's
what you see.
So you want to build a
pixel perfect design.
The natural thing to do is to
want a one-to-one ratio
between device pixels
and CSS pixels.
So how about this viewport?
You said your width is 768,
and that's how wide
your page will be.
Well, this is actually
a really bad idea.
If you look at what actually
happens, on the left hand
screen shot, that's what you
want to happen, and on the
right hand screen shot, that's
what actually happens.
It looks tiny.
Because the page is so wide, the
browser has zoomed out the
page so that it fits
fully on screen.
And as a result, everything's
gone really small.
You can compensate for this,
but you have to go through
every single width, height, font
size, margin, in every
single CSS file of
your entire site.
It's a maintenance nightmare.
It's not worth it.
It's also not even possible.
In current browsers, when you
use that kind of viewport,
they'll mess up your font sizes,
zooming will go weird,
and it's because they'll think
you're a desktop site, even
though you actually meant
it to be a mobile site.
There was also a way of doing
this in the past with target
density DPI in your viewport.
That's been deprecated.
It doesn't work in Chrome,
Safari, Firefox, et cetera,
and never will, so ignore it.
So instead of a really wide
viewport, how about a
fixed-width viewport of a width
that's more similar to
the width of a phone?
I've heard that 320 is common.
So this is OK for legacy
fixed-width, phone-only sites.
But never use this
for new sites or
sites aimed at tablets.
Why?
Well, again, look at this
site on Nexus 4.
Nexus 4 was 384 DIPs
wide, and so it's
scaled from 320 to 384.
That's OK.
It looks decent.
But a real killer is
when you rotate
your phone to landscape.
And look at this.
The toolbar is blown
out of proportion.
It's enormous.
You can't even see the search
box on screen because it's
been pushed so far down as
the page is scaled up.
And if you try this on a tablet,
can you imagine what's
going to happen now?
We're going to scale this up
from 320 to 1280, and it's
enormous now.
So yeah, the only valid way to
make a mobile website is to
design your site with flexible
width layout, even if you're
making a dedicated mobile
site, and use a
width=device-width viewport.
That one, in fact.
So you'll see initial
scale here.
That's there to fix a feature
in iOS where, in landscape,
while often making your viewport
wider, it'll zoom in
on your page, which
looks a bit weird.
But the important thing is, this
viewport allows you just
to zoom in and out, which
is recommended for
accessibility reasons.
If you must disallow pinch
zoom, which happens on a
couple of sites-- say you're
doing a multi-finger touch
painting app or you're building
Google Maps, or
something like that--
then you can use a
second viewport.
But try to avoid it, because
letting users zoom in is a
nice thing to do.
And so these two viewports give
you the ideal page width
on all devices.
Use one of those for all mobile
or responsive sites.
Now, the device width, which
he mentioned here, it's
actually in DIPs.
So this means you get the same
width of your page in CSS
pixels whether you're on a low
DPI or a high DPI device.
This is good.
This means the CSS and
JavaScript you wrote for your
low DPI device will just work
for your high DPI device.
It's like what Pete was
saying about HDTV.
Basically, [? it allows you ?]
to scale your site up, and
it'll all look in proportion,
like an HDTV playing SD video.
Except that [? bell's ?]
is a bit smarter.
Like for text and CSS features
like border-radius, it'll
render it all crisply, taking
full advantage of the
available pixels.
So the same widths, font sizes,
borders, and so on
work, but a few things you
might want to tweak.
So Pete--
PETE LEPAGE: All right, so if
we want to display high DPI
assets in our markup or in our
CSS, there's a couple of
things that we can do.
For CSS, we need
to use a rather
large media query today.
This is going to get a lot
easier, and most browsers are
standardizing on
this line here.
So you can see that we say,
min resolution 1.5 DPPX.
Whoever chose those set of
letters right next to each
other, I'd like to
just hit, because
they're not fun to say.
But in any event, 1.5
DPPX will do that.
But for today, you need
to include all
four of those lines.
So you need the one for
WebKit, for Opera.
But I want to point out the
third line there, the min
resolution 144 DPI, because
that's also going to work in
the future.
Now, you'd think that this
device, which is 326, or 236,
or something like that, this
should classify as that.
What that number is is that's
the number of pixels at the
standard level.
So the CSS specs says
it should be
at 96 for a 1x device.
So we want this to work on a
1.5x device, so we take that
96, multiply it by 1.5.
That's where the 144
is coming from.
So if we wanted it to be a 2x
device, we'd need to do just
96 times 2.
So that's going to work great
for displaying background
images and stuff
in our markup.
If we want to query this in
JavaScript, we've got the
ability to be able to say
window.devicePixelRatio and
we'll get our device pixel ratio
back from the browser.
Now, this works pretty much
across all browsers.
The only place where it doesn't
work today is IE.
They're aware of it, so
hopefully we'll see that in
the near future.
But the nice thing about both of
these is if you specify the
markup in your CSS or you have
this and it fails, it's going
to work, because you've
already got
fallbacks in there.
Now, most browsers today are
pretty awesome at sub-pixel
layout, right?
You can say, hey, I want
something to be half a pixel
wide, and it'll go
do that thing.
So that should mean I should be
able to, on a high def or a
high DPI display, I can go do
something like this, where I
say, on a 1x display, I want
a border of one CSS pixel.
And on a 1x display, one CSS
pixel is going to be one
hardware pixel.
But on a 2x display, I want a
half a CSS pixel, which is a
one device pixel line.
You think this works?
Yeah, no.
Of course not.
On Firefox and IE, they round
up, and they're always going
to give you a one
pixel border.
But on WebKit browsers,
they round down.
So you get no border.
So you want to really test
exhaustively if you want to
use something like this.
But realistically, if you want
to have something that thin,
I'd avoid it right now.
It's going to be a little bit
more of a pain in the butt
than you want to deal with.
JOHN MELLOR: So now
some better news.
If we're doing text,
text is great.
You've got a mobile optimized
site with width=device-width,
your text is going to
be the same size
in DIPs on all devices.
You don't have to do anything.
So if you get out your ruler
now and you measured the
actual physical size, it will
differ slightly going from,
say, a phone to a desktop
or something.
But that's because of what Pete
was saying earlier about
the viewing distance.
And you'll find that the visual
angle of the characters
of your text will be the same,
even on the phone and desktop.
So your text will be
similarly legible.
It'll just be rendered slightly
more crisply on high
DPI devices, [INAUDIBLE] taking
full advantage on the
extra pixels.
You're done here.
Don't change a thing.
Now, if you got the misfortune
of serving a desktop site to
mobile browsers, now you're
in for a world of pain.
So yeah, it's tricky.
Desktop sites are 1,000 pixels
wide, give or take a bit.
The browser's going to zoom them
out to fit the full page
width on the screen.
So on a portrait phone, which is
about 300 to 400 DIPs wide,
this means your site's going to
be scaled down by a factor
of three or so.
And it's going to be tiny.
But that's OK.
You can zoom in, and by zooming
in, text will become
legible again, right?
Well, there's a slight problem
with this, as always.
So when you got wide columns of
text, suddenly everything
breaks down.
Once you've zoomed in such that
the text is legible, the
text is now wider than the
screen, which means you have
to pan from side to side
for every line
of text you're reading.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, come on.
Who doesn't love that?
JOHN MELLOR: Woo!
Look I'm [? scrolling! ?]
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, no.
JOHN MELLOR: It's just
not practical.
So to combat this, when viewing
desktop sites with
wide columns, many mobile
browsers reformat the text
using a text auto-sizing
algorithm.
So on the left, you see this
page as it was originally
designed, and on the right, you
see how it gets rendered
in Chrome for Android
on a phone.
You'll notice that the wide
left hand column has
changed text size.
The header has gone from 24 to
32 pixels, and the main body
text has gone from 15
pixels to 26 pixels.
But, in the meantime, the narrow
right hand column has
stayed a constant 13 pixels
in font size.
So why are narrow columns
different from wide columns?
Well, this is what text
auto-sizing does.
It permanently scales the CSS
font size of any wide columns
of text, such that when you
double tap to zoom in on that
block of text, which fits the
block to the screen width, the
text will then be legible.
This is used on mobile by
Chrome, Safari, Firefox,
Internet Explorer, notable
exceptions being Opera and
[INAUDIBLE].
You'll notice that not even the
font size nor the layout
change when you zoom
in and out.
This all happens when the
page is first laid out.
So it's used by four browsers,
and you'll find that all of
them have different
exciting quirks.
PETE LEPAGE: Yay!
JOHN MELLOR: So by now you're
probably wondering, how do I
avoid text auto-sizing?
It's kind of a fallback.
The browser does it because
it has [? two  bits. ?]
You never want it to happen.
So because it triggers on wide
columns, by far the best thing
to do is just make your
page narrower, OK?
So ideally, you use responsive
web design techniques to
reformat your page for mobile
device sizes, or, if you must,
use a dedicated mobile site.
But whatever you do, just make
sure it's a width=device-width
narrow page.
If you're stuck serving a
desktop page to mobile
browsers, well, there's still
a bit you can do.
You can split up your wide
columns of text into multiple
narrower columns side by side.
And that way, because
they're narrow,
they won't get modified.
So it sort of works, but
it's not great either.
And then finally, there are some
ways you can disable text
auto-sizing, but use this
only as a last resort.
It'll disable it for the subtree
under that selector,
but only use it for quirks like
a menu being auto-sized
or other strange things
going on.
Don't use it for wide columns of
text, or else, when you pan
from side to side, users are
going to have the problem that
we had earlier before and
are just going to
give up on your site.
PETE LEPAGE: So we've talked
about text, we've talked about
other stuff.
But images really are one of the
most important things on
our websites today.
Talked yesterday during the
keynote that images are up to
60%, or average about 60%
of the weight of a page.
So let's talk about the web
images and the stuff that
we're doing there.
JOHN MELLOR: So it depends on
type of graphic what happens.
For vector images, they'll
seamlessly get crisper on high
DPI displays.
The same thing happens for
text-- the browser just does
everything for you.
But with raster images, they'll
get stretched, usually
using bilinear interpolation,
and you'll find they'll start
looking really crap.
So an obvious and future-proof
solution is to replace as many
raster images as possible
with vector images.
So how can you do that?
PETE LEPAGE: Well, it would be
nice if we could use vector
images for everything, but
obviously we can't.
For graphics that have text on
it and if you want a specific
font, using something like
Google Fonts or other web font
services, or Unicode
characters, is
a really good way.
You can use Unicode characters
very easily for bullets as
you're going through.
If you're looking for a couple
of symbols, it works well for
that as well.
There's a bunch of really great
icon fonts that you can
use that give you really
easy access to lots
of different icons.
But one of the problems with
icon fonts is that they're
single color, right?
You can't change the color of
one part of an icon and have
another part some
different color.
So that's where SVG works
really well--
Scalable Vector Graphics.
Because you can have it whatever
color you want, and
because it's a vector graphic,
it can get bigger and smaller
as easily as you want it to.
And then finally, using CSS3,
if you've got gradients,
backgrounds, rounded corners,
anything like that, it works
really well for that
kind of stuff
Now, we've talked a little bit
about background images
already, so we won't spend too
much time on this, but just
want to call out again, you need
to have these four lines.
Now, this is great
for the 1.5x.
If you want to have a
2x, you'd need to
have another one.
Now, the 2x will work on this,
and it'll get all the 1.5x.
But you may want to
go and do a 2x.
You may decide that 1.5x, it's
not worth my trouble.
I'm just going to do the 2x.
You may decide that you want
to do one for everybody.
And then one other thing--
always having
that fallback there.
If you decide to use the
background shorthand, don't
forget to reset the
size on an image.
Because the background
shorthand will reset
this size on that.
Another technique you can
use is using highly
compressed 2x images.
And this actually works
fantastically well.
You can see those two
images there.
They both came from the
same original image.
On the left is a 1x JPEG.
So it's JPEG at 300 pixels
by 300 pixels.
I saved it as a quality
90 in Photoshop.
And then on the right hand side,
I did the same thing.
I took the original image,
but I rescaled it.
Instead of going to 300 by 300
pixels, I set it to 600 pixels
by 600 pixels, and I set
the JPEG quality to 30.
So I went from 90 all
the way down to 30--
cranked it way down.
The file size difference
is huge, right?
I went from a 62K file
down to a 36K file.
Saved like 30 some odd percent
on that file size.
So great from a file
size perspective.
And when we actually zoom in
and look at the image, it
looks really good.
In fact, even on a 1x display,
I think it looks better than
the original image.
Even look at the bow of the
ship, look at the little bulb,
look at the cranes--
everything is just
much sharper.
Now, this is great for most
images, but there are a few
places where this doesn't work,
where you need to test
this a little bit.
If you have a lot of color
gradients, you may see some
banding in your colors.
If that's really important and
you want to make sure that you
don't hit that, you can use WebP
as another technique to
make sure that your
images look great.
On the left is a 2x JPEG
saved at quality 80.
So I cranked the quality
up, and I made them
both the same size.
And on the right is
a 2x WebP image.
So the quality level
is the same.
They're both the same
physical size.
And it went from a 145K all the
way down to a 38K file.
So huge file savings.
Now, the one disadvantage that
we have with WebP is that it's
not supported across
all browsers.
So that means you're going to
need to do some type of
feature detection, either
JavaScript, which there are
some pretty significant
disadvantages to that, or
server side.
Or you can use some services
like PageSpeed, which is
available as a Google service.
You can download an Apache
or a plug-in for nginx.
Yesterday, Ilija Gregoric did
a session on PageSpeed, and
tomorrow he's doing
one on WebP.
So if this is an interesting
thing to you, which it should
be to every developer in here,
I really would recommend
checking that out.
WebP can save you upwards of
30% in your file sizes, and
that's huge.
JOHN MELLOR: OK, so
Peter [INAUDIBLE]
resolution switching, swapping
out images for high resolution
images today.
In CSS, use media queries
to swap them out.
And in HTML, well, there's
actually no easy way, and so
you'll just provide a highly
compressed 2x image, and it
seems to work well.
In the near future, there are
some new features which make
this slightly easier.
In the CSS, there's the
image-set function.
This is part of CSS 4.
It's currently implemented in
Chrome and Safari and provide
a [INAUDIBLE]
list of several image URLs
wherever you [INAUDIBLE]
a single one.
And you annotate each one with a
device pixel ratio for which
it is designed.
This is cool.
The browser will automatically
choose the most appropriate
image based on the device's
device pixel ratio.
And in future, browsers might
be even slightly cleverer.
So a browser on a 2x device
might still choose to download
the 1x image if it's on a very
poor bandwidth constrained
connection.
Another nice thing is the
browser will scale down the
image to fit within the
same original size.
So you don't need a separate
background size property as in
the media queries approach.
But other browsers will
ignore image-sets.
They don't know about
it at the moment.
So make sure to always provide
a fallback image
like that top one.
So there's an analogous thing
for HTML, the srcset attribute
for the image element.
This is still under
discussion.
It's not really implemented
yet.
But you can do the same thing.
You provide a [INAUDIBLE]
list of different files with
their device pixel ratio.
There's an additional
feature--
you can also provide width-based
break points, a
bit like you get in
media queries.
So you can serve different
images to mobile devices as to
desktops and so on.
So OK, we still have to do
resolution switching for
fixed-width images, both
now and in the future.
What about for flexible-width
images?
So by a fixed-width image,
we mean something like
a logo or an icon.
It stays the same size in CSS
pixels on all devices.
But a flexible-width image is
something which you say went
to 100% and will actually scale
with the page size.
Unfortunately, these are much
harder, and there are no good
solutions today.
But let's go through
them quickly.
JavaScript image replacement
is quite popular.
Typically, there'll be some
script that runs and replaces
images at runtime based on the
screen [INAUDIBLE] width
properties of the device.
You have to be careful of this
because many of them don't
load any images at all
until the [INAUDIBLE]
loaded event of your page
or when you reach the
bottom of your HTML.
But by that point, about a third
of the content of your
page is already downloaded.
And so what this means is that
the images are going to start
showing up really late.
You can adjust image replacement
more efficiently
if you embed the image [? SSE ?]
in your HTML
pointing to a very low
resolution version of the
image, which is always loaded,
and then users will get an
instant feedback.
They'll see an image.
And later on, you replace it
with a high resolution image.
So users don't have to wait,
but they still get the full
quality eventually.
And you do a double download,
but the first download is very
small, because it's a low
resolution image.
So it's not so bad.
You can also switch between
images using lots of media
queries if you combine
the width and
resolution media queries.
But this gets really complicated
really quickly.
If you do this by hand, you're
going to get it wrong.
You need like 10 different
lines duplicating
images and so on.
It's tricky.
There are some server-side
solutions.
You can sniff to use an agent
of the device, and based on
that, serve an appropriate
image.
The problem is Apple decided
that iOS devices should have
the same user agent both for
retina and non-retina devices.
So you can't actually
tell how many pixels
need to serve them.
Another server-side solution is
set cookies on the client,
as the first thing in your
head or something.
And then when the browser
requests images, it'll
probably send those cookies,
and the server can use the
cookie, while you're within the
screen width and height
and so on, to serve an
appropriate image.
This sort of works, but the
first few images might be
requested without the cookie,
because browsers use a
pre-load scanner.
And so they'll start downloading
images before you
actually run the JavaScript
to set the cookie.
You can also set the base href
of your page such that any
images with relative paths
will be downloaded from a
particular directory.
If that directory includes
a screen width and DPR,
[INAUDIBLE] ratio, then the
server can similarly use URL
rewriting to serve an
appropriate image for each
type of device.
So that's actually a reasonable
approach, but it's
quite invasive.
You have to modify your servers
so they understand
things being open to different
directories.
So it's not perfect,
So what's coming up
in the future?
I mentioned [INAUDIBLE] image
srcset attributes.
There's also a picture element
that's being proposed as
another way of specifying
different images to HTML.
But with both of those, you get
the same problems you had
with the media queries above
in that you get this
complicated tangled mess of
width-based break points and
resolution-based break points.
And it's really hard to actually
serve the right
images to the right devices.
The Client Hint header
is interesting.
It's a proposal that browsers
might in the future send the
device pixel ratio and the
device width along with every
HTTP request.
This would allow servers
to serve the
perfect image reliably--
none of this user agent sniffing
or cookies or base
href stuff.
And my personal favorite choice
is using progressive
image formats coupled with
smarter browsers.
The idea is that when browsers
see a wide image, they would
download enough bytes to
make that high quality.
But If they see a narrow image
or they're on a narrow device,
they would stop downloading
the rest of the
image part way through.
And so they would get enough
quality for the size it's
actually being displayed at,
because they're never going to
show it bigger.
So that's under discussion, and
we'll see how that goes.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Canvas images are another
interesting one.
Drawing on a canvas effectively
is just a raster
image, right?
You're not doing anything
different.
It's not a vector image
or anything like that.
So if we want to draw on a
canvas image, we need to make
sure that it's scaled
appropriately, that we've got
the right number of pixels.
So when we actually say, hey,
browser, give me a canvas, it
creates this thing called
the backing store.
And the backing store is what
actually stores the pixels and
says, OK, this should be this.
And this is where we want to
make sure that we've got the
right size.
So we want to make sure that
on a 2x display or 1.5x
display, that we scale that
backing store to be the
appropriate size so that our
images appear sharp.
Now, there's a couple of times
when we might not want to
scale our canvas
backing store.
Think resource-constrained
devices--
some phones, some tablets.
We don't necessarily want to
go and scale those canvases
bigger, because every single
canvas we could be using four
times the memory that
we'd be normally
using for a 1x canvas.
So we want to be a little
bit careful with that.
So in order to scale our canvas,
you'd think we could
use something like
this, right?
We could say, hey, here's our
canvas, and we're going to
check our device pixel ratio.
And if we want to scale it,
we're going to say, OK, if
it's bigger than one, let's go
ahead and we'll change the CSS
size and we'll set the CSS size
to its original size.
And we'll set the canvas size to
be whenever that ratio is,
and then we'll do a little
scale, right?
That's going to work,
isn't it?
Yeah, no.
WebKit browsers introduced
this thing called the
webkitBackingStorePixelRatio.
Say that 10 times fast.
And the
WebkitBackingStorePixelRatio
always will return one, except
in Safari on the desktop on a
Mac Pro Retina.
So it's literally one case that
we need to deal with this
on, where it returns two,
because it's a 2x display.
They say, oh, hey, this
is a big device.
We should be able
to automatically
scale it for you.
So they scale it for us.
So we just want to double check
what that value is so
that we don't have to
go scale it again.
Because we don't want to
necessarily scale it to four
times as big and use four
times as much memory.
Now, the good thing here is that
Apple just checked in a
change a couple of weeks ago--
in fact, just at the
end of April--
that changes this behavior.
So we won't have to deal with
this in the near future.
But for now, this is something
that we need to check.
So there's one last thing I want
to cover before we start
to wrap up a little bit.
And that's just making sure that
you serve high res icon
files on all of your websites.
All of you have been probably
playing on your Pixels, and
you've noticed some of those
icon files look like--
yeah, it's not pretty, right?
So making sure that in your ICO
file, the multi-resolution
file, you've got a 32 pixel by
32 pixel and a 16 by 16 pixel.
And if you're serving up PNG,
you want to make sure that
you're serving a 32
pixel as well.
So John and I went through and
spent a lot of time as we were
preparing for this.
We realized that there were
really seven things.
You can boil this whole talk
down to seven main points.
JOHN MELLOR: Mmhmm.
So yes, if you set
width=device-width on your
viewports, your CSS pixels will
initially be the same
size as your DIPs, your Device
Independent Pixels.
And so you won't have to worry
about the two kinds of pixels
until you zoom in.
But even then, you don't need
to care about that too much.
So life will be easier.
If instead you set no viewports
at all, or you try
to set a fixed-width viewport or
something, you're going to
be in a world of hurt.
Your fonts are going to
get scaled weirdly.
Your site may get
scaled weirdly.
Your zoom's going to
be a bit weird.
Yeah, try and stick to
width=device-width
whenever you can.
PETE LEPAGE: I'm going
to show you two.
That device pixel ratio varies
anywhere from 1.3 up to 3.
Somebody's probably before
4 at some point.
John laughs at me when I say
somebody's probably going to
do 5 or 7 or 10, because
somebody's just got to
outclass somebody else,
but it's true.
JOHN MELLOR: So whenever
possible, use
vector image formats.
They'll automatically scale and
rendered more crisply on
the high DPI devices using
the appropriate pixels.
PETE LEPAGE: Use the media
queries whenever you can.
It's a real easy way to specify
the appropriate images.
JOHN MELLOR: For images in your
HTML, it's a reasonable
option to serve highly
compressed 2x images and not
worry about serving different
images to different devices.
PETE LEPAGE: And finally for
canvas, just beware of that
webkitBackingStorePixelRatio.
You don't want to end up scaling
stuff multiple times
and going from there.
Now, the other thing that we
wanted to mention was that the
I/O organizers were like, you
must have a call to action at
the end of every session.
They were sort of adamant
about it.
Well, ours is really simple.
Go build beautiful.
Go make the web look
pretty, please.
You guys all have Pixels.
You all have friends with
high DPI displays.
Just go make the
web look nice.
So with that, I want to say
thank you guys very much.
JOHN MELLOR: Thank you all.
PETE LEPAGE: Our slides
are linked up there.
John and I are going to head up
to the Four Questions Bar,
and like good bartenders,
we're going
to answer your questions.
Sadly, we're not going to be
that good bartenders and won't
be serving you booze.
That was last night.
But we'll do our best to answer
all your questions and
provide anything else
that we can for you.
So thanks everybody.
[APPLAUSE]